this one here is more personal no
because we both have seen our film
goodbye promise yeah and when I'm kind
of been an interesting we're kind of an
interesting predicament here as the
response so far has been has been
critically you know maybe more favorable
than we ever could have imagined for
just such a small little film where
we're just rolling the camera and so our
initial plan all along has been we're
going to do our one-week run in LA and
then we're going to release it online
you know and now of a sudden we're
starting to get some feedback that you
know what you guys should maybe instead
of doing that immediately maybe you guys
should try to see it and get it over to
New York to try to get the the New York
Times and some of the media there sure
you get what do you guys think I'm kind
of leaning on you here for you know
meeting on your shoulder you know open
on my ears I definitely I definitely
think for both of us we have small films
that we need to get as much press as we
can to help spread the word because
there's only so much our circles can
reach because you know we have our
online circles we have our social
network and I know there are limits to
that and so for us I mean it is why here
at Davos films we hired a publicist
we're really trying to just get as much
press out there because we want to have
some random person read that there's
just more of a chance of people you know
doing and doing things like talk to me
you guys because if we can reach these
different circles it's just going to
help increase that that word of mouth
and I think that would be that's a great
idea to try and that's what we're trying
to do with film festivals we're trying
to play la we're trying to play
somewhere on the East Coast we're trying
to you know hopefully play like you know
Toronto independent next to the Toronto
Film Festival you know we're trying to
play somewhere in Europe you know we
really try to play those things because
then when hopefully we get press around
those things
that then helped the word of mountain
online there's one thing I mean access
is one thing in that and it's and it's
fantastic to just say like yep the film
is online but without without without
curators to see ya idea to find it then
there they would never they would never
so nice and I think that if you can get
you know you're the curators for your
film if you can get that without doing
the run in New York great it either run
in New York helps you get that awesome
do whatever it takes to help you get
those things because for instance we
released our first feature films free
online and the only reason it's getting
play is because I'm reaching out to
blogs that hit our target audience
asking them to please watch the film and
if they like it then write about it on
their blog and then we'll get you know
like a couple hundred hits straight from
that blog post that otherwise would have
never happened so it's just really
trying to really target exactly and
finding those little pockets and kind of
doing a crowdsourcing you come a little
bit with and then hopefully you hit like
a hammer a nail hammered a nail review
and then it just goes you know like kind
of thing so it's just all about reaching
those people that you need to reach that
are your audience yeah and how much of
it how much thought went into that to
releasing your first film online for
free like is that something you
deliberated on that was something it
came to a point where like why is it not
online exactly like we literally I keep
you on this happens more more now which
is really starting to scare me that
we've been together this long we now
complete each other's thoughts so so
much it's not just cute it's kind of
borderline scary yeah but literally I
called him on the phone I was driving
home that's like we need to release
perfect in online he's like I literally
had that thought that's today how about
that that was like I was driving to work
and was like why is this not just on why
we put on Vimeo or something ridiculous
yeah and then yeah three hours later
yeah so we're one of the few feature
films on vimeo and we know Jason I'm
totally razandrich zondi Jason sandy who
works for community also runs shorts of
the week short of the week calm which is
a great site if you're a short releasing
and short online to try and get curated
on there but he saw that we had our
feature on there and so he put it in
this special group of like feature films
on vimeo and so we get a number of plays
just from that because we're in the
minority of a feature full feature film
on video so but you know i mean the
great thing about and this was a luxury
that not every filmmaker is gonna have
obviously but with perfect n like we we
were in this weird situation where we
happen to have enough money to make the
movie in the bank so we didn't have to
incur any debt to make it so when we
were done making it we were like okay
we're not yeah that's fine so so it's
not like we haven't felt compelled by
bullsh well shoot we've got 40 grand in
credit card debt we've got to pay off
like what are we gonna do with this
movie it was really just like you know
we had you know we played a few
festivals and you know people resonated
with it yeah yeah and then we were
secure oh shoot it's not doing any good
just sitting on ourselves like that but
it's finding the second wind which is
great which is what you hear you but it
is funny now though like you know having
just finish this movie which is I mean
technically leaps and bounds above our
first film and this way it should be
like every movie should be better than
the last one of the ones that we doing
so it's like you know having that out
there I'm like but it's not it's not
representative of what we're doing now
because it's like two years old but it's
still people did you know what people
like it and they find it then I'm
actually
you